so
so
deliver us deliver us from the plague
from hunger from war this has been the
cry of mankind throughout all time
blinded by ignorance filled with terror
he lashed out against the black plague
with witchcraft
against typhus with superstition and so
in maddened efforts to stem the
terrifying ravages of epidemics
prejudice and intolerance
too often resulted in cruel and vicious
treatment of those suffering from
contagious diseases
despite the raging panic of ignorance
the lurking danger of contagion
scientists of many nations went to work
painfully they labor to nurse the
flickering light of research into a
broad search light of knowledge
using every means of communication to
share their findings with each other
it was the dutchman logan hook whose
research helped provide scientists
everywhere with a new and powerful
vision of the microscope
now at last the hidden enemy could be
examined under the probing searchlight
of science
the hunt was on for contagious diseases
and their causes
wherever they existed
in italy pioneered the work on the
origin and growth of microscopic
organisms
he proved that fermentation did not take
place in sealed containers
but occurred only through contact with
the microorganisms present in the air
jenner in england painstakingly evolved
the basic principles of vaccination
and a little british girl was the first
to wince at the sting of a vaccinating
needle
and pasteur in france his was the
brilliant research
that resulted in the discovery of the
causes of contagious diseases
he proved that microbes were at the root
of such diseases
and thus medical science marched forward
bringing light where once there had been
darkness
hope where once there had been
and in germany [ __ ] identified and
isolated the [ __ ] bacillus
and the dreaded germ of cholera
across the sea in america walter reed
and his colleagues sought to prove
that the mosquito was the sole
transmitter of yellow fever
they offered their lives and won and so
the old prejudices were smashed and the
free exchange of information forged
modern weapons
like the ancient diseases of mankind
[Music]
then in the course of the 19th century
the world underwent a striking change
gave birth to the industrial revolution
transformed man's way of life
men women and children crowded into
cities became part of a vast machine
deprived of sun and fresh nourishment of
the country men's bodies rusted
became more vulnerable to contagion
new means of transportation brought the
world tight and close together
making it one tremendous and congested
city
from a disease-infected zone the
traveler now became
unwittingly a carrier of deadly germs
wherever he went
the germs stayed and spread
epidemics break out far from the known
infected areas
country to country continent to
continent the deadly cargo of microbes
is transported
menacing on a vast scale the very
existence of humanity
mass infection and epidemics are a
threat to every city to every nation
scientific and medical work on a local
scale are no longer enough
thus in common defense nations join in
international agreement in the battle
against epidemics
medical agreements and protective
measures are formulated quarantine
measures extended
frontier control set up when an epidemic
strikes
that country is subjected to special
restrictive measures
suspected carriers are isolated and step
by step
the dangers of contagion grow less and
[Music]
less
war the first great world war like all
wars
sucking mankind down to misery and death
and together with war
pestilence and disease epidemics wreak
havoc greater than war
wipe out civilian populations the
problem is everywhere and must be dealt
with internationally
a network of medical information is
swiftly organized through radio
newspapers pamphlets bulletins the
league of nations spreads information
that all may fight the contagion of
diseases
in geneva this immense storehouse of
information becomes part of the arsenal
of embattled doctors and scientists
everywhere
health reports are received checked
filed
collated and sent out again ready for
use
because now trains are entering and
leaving stations
ships leave and dock at foreign ports
millions live work
and suffer
for the sailor it's always hard to say
goodbye
harder still when your wife is sick
burning with fever
and you have to pull anchor there's
nothing to worry about you say
she'll be all right in a couple of days
besides
you need the job neither of you suspect
typhus the black plague
and so goodbye both have become carriers
of death dealing germs
germs that will blast the lives of
shipmates germs
traveling across seas to start a
terrible epidemic
at any moment any place
epidemic starts anytime any place
wherever you are
wherever she is now in a hospital there
are no doubts
it is contagious
immediate action a life at stake and
though she might infect
or has already infected who is she for
friends
for kinfolk send the alert everywhere to
every nation to every port in every
language
easy enough to locate all ships which
left the area before the outbreak
message to all ships at sea the
quarantine service must know the health
condition aboard ships in every port
every day almost every moment for
epidemic strikes anytime
any place wherever you are
ah
a protective mechanism is set in motion
the quarantine service issues the
necessary orders to the ship for
investigation and control
the ship is stopped the sick man brought
ashore
all others are fully protected by
two
inoculation
please
and now the ship is thoroughly
disinfected rats are hunted out of the
hiding places
cyanide gas does the trick teams of
specialists fumigate the boat from stem
to stern
from state rooms to the home everything
completely disinfected
before the ship is able to sail on in
safety
right
such cooperation protects mankind from
recurring epidemics
international cooperation provides
immediate action to smash a swift
striking enemy
today there are no distances today the
airplane links continents
as trains link cities today the peoples
of the world are one
people joined by wings over the globe
today people of all races of every level
move from country to country in a matter
of hours
today vital medical control is
established around the modern points of
international exchange the airports
the network of health information and
services has been extended here from the
seaport organization
but is this sufficient how long does it
take before a potential epidemic can be
detected
from one continent to another only a few
hours flying time
but cholera takes longer to show itself
and yellow fever
three to six days and the incubation
period of smallpox from 7 to 16 days
[Music]
passengers in a modern plane look
perfectly healthy
they are but how do we know
that little girl when she got the doll
did she receive
germs as well some passengers may be
germ carriers
perhaps already in the incubation stage
they'll reach their destination before
any symptoms show
the quarantine service can't keep every
plane and passenger grounded for several
days to affect thorough medical control
today that system of defense is no
longer enough
today epidemics must be crushed at the
very source
unfortunately in some countries
contagious diseases exist in an endemic
state
that is permanently
india for instance has certain areas
that are always infected with cholera
this play can extend to western europe
in africa some forms of malaria still
rage
germs that might easily be transmitted
to south america
and cholera in japan could strike
suddenly at the west coast of the united
states
permanently infected zones are localized
but may cover large areas of territory
sometimes entire continents
modern transport poses new dangers of
complete universal contagion
the struggle against epidemics is a
global one for the danger of death is
worldwide
then what is the answer
within the framework of the united
nations a new organization exists
to promote the welfare of all people the
world health organization
in its first assembly july 1948 director
general dr
chisholm declared that this organization
was physically prepared to raise the
health level of all people
and to forever destroy the human
afflictions of malaria cholera
tuberculosis and syphilis
the prime objective of the world health
organization is the fight against
disease
on a global scale
the representatives of nearly every
nation have signed the great
charter of health this means an
organization with the authority
and means to act epidemics no matter
what part of the world they may infect
are a potential danger to all other
nations the world health organization
will make full use of every existing
means education
prevention cure all peoples of every
race and belief will be helped by
doctors from all races and nations
a tremendous movement of world
solidarity is now born
inoculation already widely used will be
extended
millions of people will be given
prophylactic injections
a worldwide system of medical control
will exist
everywhere
hey
enormous quantities of serums vaccines
new and powerful drugs such as
penicillin and sulfanilamides
are already being manufactured at
increasingly lower cost
crates of ampules are shipped to all
parts of the world ready for emergency
measures
the constant flow of up-to-date
information from every nation and every
tongue
now makes it possible to apply the
latest discoveries of modern medicine
cholera broke out in egypt shortly
before the first assembly meeting of the
world health organization
the first cases were instantly reported
and from cairo every nation was
immediately alerted
new york was then the clearinghouse for
the incoming orders for vaccines and
equipment
needed to fight the epidemic that was
menacing egypt
dr calderon issued orders how about
sulfadiazine
serums needles syringes anything else
anything don't worry about the payment
the world health organization will pay
let's get going fast the answer was
swift
from france china indochina soviet union
and the united states
vaccines were shipped by the fastest
means planes flew the precious fluid
into egypt
they brought thousands of needles
syringes other indispensable instruments
in record time the egyptian government
had the entire population immunized
a sick put into isolation wards and the
infected areas methodically disinfected
the epidemic was checked and within
three months
completely eradicated from egypt
wow
in the eternal battle a struggle has
been won
one by international cooperation but
there is yet a tremendous task before us
a task for all peoples by all peoples
the lives of these little children
too must be saved that a light of hope
may revive the courage of those who
suffer
that mothers might yet smile in a new
world
[Music]
now